Outlet pass redirected into Columbus territory
jackets with a nice feed on that right wing
back handed towards the net offer the save Blues
quickly clear outlet and ahead here on the left
wing for Hayes Hayes looks cross ice Kyu unable to
get a stick on it and the jackets counter in the
zone nice move thrown in front turn in and haer
looks behind him and it's into the net the blue
jacket strike early it's Aug for a goal starts
down on their own end defensive play Hayes tries
to thread to knil Across the ice and you can
see chikov speed he's going to take the outside
because he's created it but then moves inside and
now baronov he's so good at that he protects the
puck and gets it back to the middle of the ice
and as he does marenko does what marenko does
well great release into the middle of the net the
Blue Jackets score early here here's chinika who
picked up an assist on the first goal from the
right Point blue is able to come away moving
in across ice pass moving there Reeves got a
piece of it and here's from the crowd big hit
there by baronov much to the light then takes
a cross check shot towards the net missed that
was Thomas that just got rocked and now Thomas
he's got a breakaway moving right and Thomas
scores Wow first gets rocked gets back up throws
a cross check and then scores out a break o yeah
I mean that's the type of player he is Bron off
and that was a tough introduction for him but
you can see how the pinch is up the wall and that
puck comes perfectly from Deep to Thomas who had
anticipated that play and as he did he put himself
up all by himself and for Robert Thomas to Center
on the top line here's corenko kicks from skate
the stick but defending was beam now the jackets
will walk out of Their Own Zone little more than
three to go here in this first period moving in
shot scores Adam Fang Tilly again 2-1 Columbus
nice job in their own end they're all together
in fan Tilly with a slick little pass and see
how close they are but Kent Johnson right here
slows it down opens up that lane waits for fanti
to arrive as he does sets himself and there's no
chance for Hopper on that shot just over the pad
below that glove and he tucks it inside that far
post the Blue Jackets he's kept them together here
tonight yeah but it's you know it's nice for a
young player to come up and get the opportunity to
find shot linski save offer rinsky not he thinks
he had a better spot to hit you were saying about
the young guys get called up you know you want to
find a home feeds the left wing into the slot
s the one time blue jacket with a shot there
and geves down will cover up proog chukov proov
baronov sets the screen shot goal poost genov
had hoer beat Final seconds here another attempt
Hopper's got it juggles and then recovers that
got deflected that last shot by his own player
maybe Paro there's that shot off the post bronos
just ducked out tucked in that left side just
enough that one gets deflected down hord's there
Here Comes ginot puts the brakes up drops it there
and it's picked off sprinting through the neutral
zone and across the line that's kyou kyou with a
shot gaves the save perunovic top of the circle
Far Side he'll get it back screen set in front on
grees quick Shot Pat a rebound still a loose Puck
and it's punched wide of the net to the face we
still haven't seen him back but the Blue Jackets
penalty kill doing a good job here gaves him
especially that second save wow just a scramble
let's see how quick he gets to his feet just up
to push across that's impressive down the wing
looks deflected off the blocker another attempt
gaves Under Siege three outstanding consecutive
saves as you know you're down a couple key peny
killers at Jenner and cor and up top good hard
work Dan for started by winning that face off
they couldn't get to clear but valuable seconds
killed in the corner and Hubble this sequence for
Greaves ready for the next one ready for the next
one here's bstr picks up the loose Puck bounced
off of it Blues in the clearing pass looking
for Hayes hay sends it ahead moving in Shen
with a shot and that quick glove hand again
sandwich in that group a game in Toronto
against the Maple Leafs down the right
wing baronov Maro scores cheetah Tick Tac Toe
the all important insurance goal and it's 3-1
Columbus hey don't want to back off with the
lead and this line they started it they've
got some chemistry and baronov there does not
win the face off look at this play by the Blue
Jackets as they Crow the puck excellent job
to steal it and then all the way up the ice
you could feel it you can feel if something
was going to happen too much time too much
skill and Marko here he defers the shot over to
chikov and chikov yeah that third goal for this
team effective players in front Jack looking for
more g r in front marchenko and good R trailing
marchenko will pick it up crosses the line
marchenko burst to the front of the net and
now backand attemp Hopper got a piece of that back
now for Gina COV a r shot missing the mark picked
up by good Ro little more than a minute left in
the Ley penalty Blues get it up chov drills it
and scores what a shot a power play goal and
for cheet cob his second consecutive goal in
the middle of the ice good job by the Blue Jackets
here they're going to get this puck back the Jeff
Wilder big play you can see this battle it's a
little bit of a scrum okay okay everything's fine
on the weak side of the ice is chikov it rolls to
him and boy I tell you he's got a wicked shot and
here he displays it perfect now Faulk looks to
feed the front I don't know how they think they
can get those passes through now Verana quick one
timer and look at Greaves move laterally to make
that stop wow could didn't do it broken play
allows the St Louis moo to get an opportunity
but check G there he's there and he finds it
quick push there's the puck oh outstanding and
for Hayes he just sees that white Linsky tried
to get a stick on it bar side set to the point
for crew Kyu Waits left side goes down the left
wing in front shot scores Thomas with his second
of the night and both goals for St Louis here's
the play Shen just kind of throws in see it stops
GES catches it there that change of pace maybe he
did see it he just that change of pace threw him
off a little bit and then that rebound comes right
out to Thomas who's got two on the night that one
he almost completely missed as he stayed with it
missed that one and then it as it bangs around he
puts it in so picked up by the blues on the far
side Shen to the point a quick shot loose Puck
down is is Greaves and he hangs on long enough to
get the whistle and here looking for the jackets
to close the deal it's been a fun night sure has
in front oh that one awfully close went right
through the blue paint pass on the wing seconds
remain jackets have it saucered ahead race for
the puck Tex's there texier walks in scores 3.8
left on the clock the empty net goal seals it for
Columbus nice job in tight those cross eyes passes
are tough to make through the Blue Jackets defense
how about this play little poke he lets crew go
to the outside then he pops himself in the inside
still 3.8 seconds left for mality here for fanan
company the Blue Jackets at home on a back to back
and what great Victory and Jack congratulations
to him his first National Hockey League win